I really want to start with is sincere
congrats on the movie I really enjoyed
this I thought you guys did a great job
and especially Francis he really he
really did a great job with this
um uh I have individual questions for
you guys uh Jason I have to start with
you
um you're generally not offered roles
like this so when Francis called you and
mentioned the character of flip at any
point did you think you were on an
episode of punked
it's actually funny I think I was like
uh slicing someone's neck and we were on
set and I was covered in blood and
Francis was like we were goofing around
and he's like I have this great role for
you it's a comedy and he told me about
it I'm like I love to do it no one's
ever picked me for that so you know I
got to spend a lot of time with Francis
and uh became dear friends so it's all
his and he killed it and this movie's
amazing but it's it's his you know it's
his idea Marlo I've really I really
enjoyed your work in this and I also
enjoyed your work in Spirited
um thank you and I'm just curious for
because these are obviously this is your
first time making movies like this uh
what surprised you about the actual
movie making process that perhaps you
didn't know going into these things I
guess I mean I always knew that movies
had big casts and crew but I didn't know
how many people would be like on the set
I thought that it was a lot of people
like either online or like in offices
doing a lot of work but no I mean those
sets are like filled with people all the
time and that was even just during covet
so I'm sure there's so many more
normally
um but I was also surprised at how
fun it was on set even during like the
super emotional scenes we were still
like laughing making jokes on set
um and so I guess I was just surprised
at how comfortable I would feel
um in this environment and yeah working
with Francis was just amazing but yeah
everything came very natural and Easy in
this movie one of the things that I
really enjoyed about this film is one of
the many things is that it's um it
doesn't talk down to kids it's a really
smart script it treats everyone with
respect can you sort of talk about that
aspect of the film that uh I guess that
I mean I think dreams take up like a big
part of everyone's lives
um and so I think that's why it appeals
for kids and adults because there are
some mature jokes in there some
references that the adults will get but
then there's also physical comedy that
the kids will laugh at and of course pig
is very much appealing to younger
audiences so I feel like it's a great
age range because of
I guess the diversity of all the jokes
and everything that happens in the movie
but Jason do anything to say about that
yeah I'm just I mean when I read the
script it was just like one of those
I've never been a part of one of those
four quadrant movies I guess you could
kind of include Aquaman but I don't
think it has the level what this does
it's just such an emotional roller
coaster everyone's crying in Aquaman so
like uh grief and loss so I'm like this
is my first time being a part of
something that yeah it's for the whole
family like grandmas and babies and dads
and moms and like everyone and I and
it's something you can watch over and
over and I think it's got a lot of
themes we were just talking about it
with someone else just going like wow
how much you can take away from it it's
one of those things they're just gonna
kind of sit with you and hopefully
return and turns out Netflix just
approved two and three oh my gosh can
you believe that it's crazy
we're joking yeah I was gonna be like
wait what I was like well with Jason
we're filming them right now it's I'm a
big manifester
I manifested this I'm going to keep
manifesting two and three by the way
it's not a joke this is going to be a
big hit on Netflix and it would not
surprise me if they want to do more but
um on that note I need to stop and I'm
just going to say sincerely congrats and
I hope the rest of your speed dating
goes well thank you so much it's good to
see you buddy take care